ينضم الينا الان من مستشفى ناصر في خان
يونس مراسلنا وائل الدحدوح وائل الحمد لله
على السلامه في البدايه
و رحم الله الشهيد سامر ابو دقه عزاؤنا
واحد وكنت انت الان في التشييع وانت
المصاب والان تقف امام الكاميرا كما وعدت
وكما تحدثت تفضل
وائل
شكرا جزيلا وشكر الله سعيكم ومصاب مصابنا
واحد كما تحدثت
وهذا يعني ربما الم جديد وجرح جديد ووجع
جديد يضاف لما هو موجود من اوجاع والام
وجروح يضاف الى هذه الصفحات التي نشاهدها
في هذه الحرب من اهوال وصور حقيقه وا
الزميل سامر ربما يعني انتم لم تشاهدوه
قبل ان ننطلق الى هذه المهمه
الرسميه نحن في نهايه المطاف كان في غايه
الحماس يعني كان مندفع
بطريقه لم يسبق لها مثيل وكان مصمما ان
يكون معي في هذه
المهمه ونحن تشجعنا اكثر عندما علمنا ان
هذه المهمه لها تنسيق وموافقه من قبل
الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبالتالي ذهبنا
الى ذلك المكان علنا نطلع العالم على صوره
جديده لم يصلها احد من قبل ولم تصلها عدسه
كاميرا من قبل وبالتالي حاولنا واجتهدنا
ويعني ان نصل الى هذا المكان وبالفعل
تمكنا من التقاط صور مرعبه غير مسبوقه
حقيقه لاصوات
الدمار يعني صور الدمار التي كانت في كل
مكان لدرجه انه ربما استغرق معنا وقت
الوصول الى المدرسه التي كان يجب ان نصل
اليها وقتا طويلا جدا جدا جدا لانه كثير
من الشوارع والاذقه التي حاولنا ان ندخل
من خلالها عبر سياره الاسعاف التي تقلنا
كانت مليئه بالدمار وفي معظم الشوارع
اضطررنا الى النزول من السياره وازاله
الركام من امام السياره ومحاوله الوصول
الى ان وصلت الى طريق مسدود لا يمكن معهه
ان تمر هذه السياره واكملنا المهمه سيرا
على الاقدام وسياره الاسعاف عادت ادراجها
لتحاول ان تجد مدخلا اخر تصل اليه على
مقربه مننا
عندما بالتاكيد نحن اتممنا المهمه وصورنا
وعملنا كل ما نريد وعندما قررنا الخروج
كان بيننا وبين سياره الاسعاف ما يقرب من
900 متر الى كيلو تقريبا لانها لا تستطيع
ببساطه الوصول
و حاولنا ان نخرج من المكان وانا يعني
كنت اقول لهم لا يجب ان نكون متجمعين يجب
ان نكون متفرقين يعني الى حد ما حتى لو
حصل شيء لو استهدفنا لو على الرغم من
الموافقه موافقه جيش الاحتلال لكن لكننا
لا نامن جانب هذا الجيش ولذلك
يعني بضعه امتار سرنا بضعه امتار باتجاه
سياره الاسعاف اي حتى حصل ما حصل نحن
حقيقه لا ندري كان عاصفه هوجاء تخطفت
جميعا و يعني
القتن كل في جهه و يعني الخوذه ذهبت
و شعرنا ب دوار ودوخه و بالكاد بالكاد
بالكاد يعني تمالكت نفسي بعد لحظات وحاولت
ان ان اتكي على بعض الركام واقوم بالفعل
وكان مجاور لنا بعض المنازل المفتوحه
والحواس
وحاولت ان ادخل لكن نظرت الى يدي نظره
شاهدت بانها تنزف نزيف شديد جدا و ادركت
انه اذا دخلت في الحواصل فانه سوف يعني
نموت نزفا وانا اتوقع اين سياتي الصاروخ
الثاني باعتبار انه ديدا الغارات
الاسرائيليه عاده مكونه من صاروخين
و قررت ساعتها في وانا في هذه الحاله ان
اضغط على الجرح بيدي الاخرى واحاول ان اصل
الى سياره الاسعاف نظرت الى شباب الدفاع
المدني كان
كانهم قد استشهدوا على الفور سامر سمعت
صوته يصرخ وينادي عن بعد ولكن في حالتي
هذه لم يكن بالامكان ابدا تقديم اي مساعده
اي عون فقررت ان اصل الى سياره الاسعاف
حتى يتسنى لنا ان ناتي بالمسعى الى هذه
المنطقه ويخلو الزميل
سامر يعني
بصعوبه وفي هذه الحاله وعندما رايت
المسعفين كانوا ينتظروننا في نهايه
الطريق حاولت ان اصرخ وا اطلب النجده ان
ان ياتوا الينا لكن يعني كما يبدو كان
الموقف خطر جدا والمسعفين يعني لم يكن
بمقدور السياره اصلا ان تدخل وهم كافراد
ترددوا كثيرا باعتبار ان المكان مكان
استهدا داف بما انهم استهدفوه
وبالتالي واصلت المسير حتى وصلتهم و يعني
طلبت منهم ان ندخل ثانيه ل ننتشل الزميل
سامر لكن قالوا يجب اولا انقاذ حياتك ومن
ثم ناتي بالسيارات سيارات اخرى بعد تنسيق
لاجلاء الزميل سامر وهذا هو ما تم هذا هو
المصاب الذي تم وكانت ربما
يعني قصه من القصص التي عايشناها وكنا بدل
ان ننقل الاحداث اصبحنا نحن الحدث ونحن
الصوره ا
ونحن تداعيات واثار هذه العدوان
وائل هل عرفت الى اي درجه كانت اصابه سامر
بليغه في البدايه يعني وكميه النزف التي
نزفها خلال الساعات الى لحظه تمكن سيارات
الاسعاف من الوصول بعد كل هذه الاتصالات
التي
قمتم بها وقامت بها شبكه
الجزيره من الواضح ان الاصابه كانت في
الجزء السفلي من من جسد الزميل سامر رحمه
الله
و يعني واضح ان النزيف كان
كبيرا ولكن بعد بعدما غادرت المكان لا
ادري ما اذا كان هدف مره اخرى ام انه لم
يستهدف لان الحاله التي وصل بها الى
المستشفى بعد اخلائه كانت حاله مزريه جدا
صعبه جدا والاصابه صعبه جدا
وا يعني في هناك تهتك شديد جدا في النصف
السفلي من الجسد وفي الاحشاء ايضا لدرجه
انه بعض اجزاء الكاميرا التي كان يحملها
كانت ملتصقه في جسده وفي اقدامه مثل وحده
الصوت الكاميرا نفسها كانها غارت في جسد
الزميل سامر ابو دقه وهذا الامر بالتاكيد
يعني يعني انه هناك ربما يكون اكثر من
استهداف يعني لكن على الاقل من المشاهدات
التي بعدما جاء الزميل سامر ابو دقه الى
المستشفى كان يعني كانت على هذه الحاله
من تهتك والاستهداف
ويعني جسده كان بالتاكيد في حاله صعبه جدا
على الاقل النصف الاخر الاحشاء والنصف
السفلي من الجسد كانت في حاله جدا صعبه
وحتى اننا بحثنا عن ذاكره الكاميرا
لنستخرج ما تمكن الزميل سامر من تصويره
والتقاطه بهذا الاندفاع وبهذه الشجاعه
وبهذه الحماسه التي كان كانت تسيطر عليه
لدرجه انه يعني انا كنت احاول دائما يعني
اقول له بحذر يا سامر بحذر يا سامر ارجع
يا سامر بحذر قليلا تنحى جانبا لكن كان
مندفعا بشكل كبير جدا وربما اراد حتى
النفس الاخير وحتى الرمق الاخير ان ينقل
للعالم ما جرى ويجري في هذه البقعه من
الارض
ولذلك مع الاسف لم نجد هذه الممري حتى
الان على الاقل
و يعني كان الصور ذهبت ادراج الرياح لكن
عزائنا رغم الفقد الكبير يعني سامر واحد
من اشجع المصورين ومن اخبرهم ومن اكثرهم
تمرسا ومن اقدمهم ومن اكثرهم اخلاصا لهذه
المهنه وشبكه الجزيره ولكن عزائنا بان
زملاء سامر ما زالوا مستمرون في
هذه حمل هذه الرساله صح واء واليام بهذا
الواجب طالما ان فينا عرق يند صحيح وانت
خير مثال انت والزملاء جميعا شكرا جزيلا
لك يا وائل والحمد لله على السلامه
وتعازينا لانفسنا ول الجميع من اسره
الشهيد سامر
الى كل الفلسطينيين الذين تابعوا من خلال
كاميرته نقله
للصوره ولما يجري والحقيقه شكرا
جز